bienvenue sur notre antenne radio et sur
notre chaîne youtube où vous pouvez
suivre en direct ce débat en radio
filmée un débat que j'ai l'honneur
d'animer avec jean-marc partie jean-marc
alors aujourd'hui le turak ce débat sera
consacré à la ville de quinze pilotes
alors je marque trois candidats sont en
lice
oui bienvenue à toutes et à tous et
merci de nous rejoindre un pourvoi ce
nouveau débat sur avec les candidats des
quinze pilotes alors trois candidats en
lice pour l'instant parce que les
élections sont encore loin et puis
peut-être que tout le monde ne s'est pas
encore déclarée bon on ne sait jamais on
en tout cas aujourd'hui nous avons comme
candidat déclaré tout d'abord par ordre
alphabétique monsieur eddy chronique
pensera aussi chronique je rappelle que
vous êtes âgé de 61 ans quand vous êtes
cadre technique dans une collectivité et
que vous conduisez la liste intitulée 15
pilotes en mouvement et vous êtes
investi également par le modem le
mouvement démocrate
vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition sein du conseil municipal
de case-pilote vous avez été maire
adjoint de 1995 à 2001 avec le maire
aristide vacanciers c'est votre
cinquième participation en tant que
conseiller ou un candidat conseiller à
ces élections municipales à quinze
pilotes deuxième candidat à par ordre
alphabétique
est ce une gêne bonsoir bonsoir alors 48
ans sapeur-pompier vous étiez maire
adjoint en 2014
élu sur la liste de races mon plaisir
mais pour 2020 vous allez mener la liste
ensemble pour le changement à
case-pilote et vous avez l'investiture
du ppm et enfin troisième candidats par
ordre alphabétique
elle rafle montplaisir bonsoir monsieur
mon plaisir oui bonsoir mesdames et
messieurs bonsoir oui rue d'être avec
vous ce soir monsieur livory permettez
moi de faire une petite rectification
parce que je suis quand même maire de la
commune je connais mais des adjoints et
conseillers
je le dis sans mais il ya eu une petite
erreur de votre part monsieur hansson
jeunes n'a jamais été à jouer en mer il
avait sur votre liste
monsieur excusez moi monsieur de vori
d'accord il était conseiller municipal
permettez moi au moins de dire les
choses dames elles sont élevées sur
votre liste
absolument d'accord bien si vous êtes
monsieur montplaisir chef d'entreprise
de profession vous êtes âgé de 71 ans
est vôtre
troisième mandat en tout cas vous
postulez à votre troisième mandat
puisque vous avez été élu en 2008 puis
réélu en 2014 vont mener la liste tous
pour quinze pilotes
vous avez le soutien de l hérault m la
république en marche ou l'art m
vous êtes je le rappelle président du ce
même c'est à dire le syndicat mixte
d'électricité de martinique qui regroupe
les maires ainsi que des élus de la cité
mais qui a pour objet ce même de donner
les grandes orientations en matière de
politique énergétique sur le territoire
de l'arctique
alors avant de passer au débat
proprement dit voyons avec vous jean
marc quatre pilotes en eau claire paru
vraiment ce soit un crédit parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses à dire dans un
silo cette ville où cette commune qui
est l'une des plus anciennes de la
technique comme vous le savez une des
plus anciennes paroisses entre 140 et
145 avec car bessin pied en prêcheur ou
encore le marin la commune a été érigée
en 1837 pour ceux qui sont amateurs
d'histoire la fête patronale
messieurs c'est le 15 août je ne vous
apprends rien ces quatre pilotes s'étend
sur environ 1800 44 hectares pour ceux
qui ont oublié ou qui ne savent pas très
bien elle est située au nord de
schoelcher et aussi de bellefontaine et
elle tire son nom du chef de chefs
caraïbes qui avait été baptisée par les
colons français pilotes qui avaient
sympathisé avec les missionnaires
jésuites et l'un des frères de pilotes
harley s'y installera plus tard dans le
sud où a été érigée la commune d
installer alors qu'un pilote comme
beaucoup de communes notamment dans le
nom car elle va longtemps tiré sans
prospérité de l'industrie sucrière la
distillerie manigat était le l'un des
fleurons de ce secteur activités avant
de fermer en 1990 comme la quasi
totalité de nos sucreries aujourd'hui
casse de l'aube tiré l'essentiel de ses
ressources de la pêche un peu de
l'agriculture et des recettes fiscales
je prends de la commune en tout cas delà
de la municipalité
alors pour vous les visiteurs et les
visiteurs qui sont intéressés je
conseille de voir ou de visiter l'église
notre dame de l'assomption et saint
joseph
non seulement parce que c'est la plus
ancienne église construite en martinique
comme si elle était restaurée réparer
plusieurs fois elle est classée aux
monuments historiques et elle a été
fortement endommagée lors du tremblement
de terre du 11 janvier 1839 une
catastrophe qui n'avait pas touché que
fort de france voilà très rapidement
optique l'audition quand pilote merci
jean marc nous sommes deux crans
du dans la commune pour prendre le pouls
de la population et connaître les
doléances des administrés un micro
trottoir réalisé par aurélie treuil et
marc françois calme au sein d'un plan
d'action pour les jeunes tuent ce dead
pour trouver du travail plus
d'infrastructures de lieu pour jouer
pour mendier opus de logements aussi que
l'activité qui développe le tourisme la
commune comme ainsi bien développé je
trouve notamment avec les restaurants ça
s'est amélioré mais il m'a quand même
beaucoup d'efforts à faire surtout au
niveau des transports
on n'a pas trop à c'est le nom de la
mort celui passé développer l'étude pour
les jeunes aussi
donc beaucoup le transport parce qu'il
ya plus de ya pas de taxis qui sort
directement de 4,9 hors de france et
qu'on était à quatre taxis a eu sur
quatre pilotes sont tous remplis
il faut qu'on patiente pour le bateau si
bien aimé le bateau c'est bien il y
aurait des choses qu'il manque c'est
surtout au niveau du transport
maintenant vient d'avoir le bateau mais
voilà c'est ça pour moi personnellement
je suis satisfait plus ou moins c'est à
dire que la commune elle en plein
développement mais c'est pas suffisant
mais pas tellement tellement pourrait
pour développer la tous ces bons gros ça
parle à quelques réactions recueillies
au fil de l'eau si je puis dire à
case-pilote notamment sur le bord de mer
qui connaît un développement depuis
l'installation de la liaison maritime
entre 15 villes hôtes et bellefontaine
monsieur propre plaisir le tirage au
sort aux a désigné pour comment pourrait
avoir la première réaction la première
intervention qu'est ce que vous pouvez
dire est ce que ça correspond à ce que
vous entendez tous les jours en tant que
maire auprès de vos administrés bien
goûter d'abord je dit bonsoir mes
administrés
ensuite je voudrais que ça correspond à
ce que je veux faire et ce que je fais
depuis 12 ans ça fait 12 ans que je suis
en campagne électorale douze ans que je
fais mon travail je suis arrivé j'ai
trouvé une ville qu'on appelait ville
dortoir un front de mer où quand on se
promenait il y avait des odeurs
nauséabonde parce qu'il y avait des
résidus la station d'épuration qui
remontait j'ai fait du front de mer ce
qu'il est avec des amis j'ai trouvé une
commune où il y avait besoin de
développer un transport
je me suis attaché à me rapprocher de la
ctn et nous avons mis en place je la
transporte que vous voyez effectivement
j'ai déjà entendu le problème du taxi
qui arrive à quinze pilotes etc est
rempli parce que depuis saint pierre il
ya eu des gens qui ont marqué et ça ce
n'est effectivement pas normal par
contre nous avons mettre dans le
transport nous prenons les gens du bourg
nous emmenons dans les quartiers les
personnes âgées qui vont faire leurs
courses au bourg donc on a amélioré sa
et puis dans l'ensemble nous avons
essayé de développer la commune dans un
esprit rurales et touristiques et dans
une économie qui se veut proche de la
population avec les pêcheurs
l'agriculture nous avons réaménagé un
marché qui n'existait plus on a
reconstruit aujourd'hui vous voyez bien
que le marché fonctionne tous les
vendredis et il ya des gens qui achètent
vous avez une église qui a fini d'être
restaurée par nous nous avons à l'heure
actuelle des projets dont je pourrais
peut-être parler on va on va on va dire
pour une première action attendu par
rapport à ce que vous avez entendu
monsieur carbonique sa regret cependant
la réalité nous n'avons pas la même
vision des choses
j'ai entendu pas mal de choses mais en
réalité qu'à ce pilote a perdu son âme
tout a été détruit comme lien social
donc je dis qu'il ya énormément de
choses à changer par rapport à la
politique qui est menée aujourd'hui et
que d'ailleurs je rejoins le temps de
vous exposer lien social qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là c'est parce que
c'est vaste c'est à dire que
le tissu associatif a été démantelée
lequel sortu de kaamelott
il est dans un état que vous savez qui
connaissait le haut niveau le l'avis
même de piloter et à aucune activité ni
pour les jeunes ni pour les personnes
âgées pour qu'ils puissent se sentir à
l'aise à voir du bien-être en matière de
sport en main aucune discipline sportive
mais les associations il y avait pas de
20 associations aujourd'hui ils nous ont
ils sont que siècle le moteur de
subventions ont été allouées aux
subventions aux associations en 2008
aujourd'hui ça aux besoins soient
coordonnés s'envolant 100 % de ce
montant de 270 milles nous sommes passés
à 14 heures donc le tissu associatif a
été détruit donc moi je dis que
aujourd'hui la ville doit soit conscient
tout ce qui a été démoli doit être
woippy mais avec vraiment une dynamique
que ceux qui existent et sont nos jeunes
même réaction ou avant vous avez une
vision particulière vous êtes un jeune
élu vous venez d'un autre et au conseil
municipal enfin volonté il ya quelques
années en 2014 vous présenter à ces
élections est ce que ce que vous avez
entendu évidemment ça n'a pas valeur de
sondage année absolument pas
scientifique nous allons nous n'avons
fait que pour mieux nos micros et notre
caméra dans les noms et les rues du
bourg
est-ce que ça correspond à ce que vous
voyez ce que vous entendez au quotidien
alors dans tout je tiens à saluer les
auditeurs bonsoir l'auditeur de
martinique première bonsoir
à tous ceux qui nous écoutent par la
radio et par le biais de l'internet il
particulièrement aux habitants de
case-pilote je souhaite également une
très bonne année 2020 à la toute la
population de 15 pilotes
alors forcément vous savez je suis
piloté je suis né à gas pilote j'ai vécu
toute ma vie à case-pilote et je tiens à
vous dire que je la connais parfaitement
cette ville et je l'aimais énormément et
je suis bien placé pour savoir qu'est ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur de notre
petite ville par exemple
alors c'est vrai que monsieur mon
plaisir
il a quand même travaillé pour la ville
mais c'est une ville comme le dit
monsieur caroni qu on a de gros
problèmes de cadre de vie
c'est une commune qui souffre d'un
manque d'attractivité énorme
les associations n'ont plus de moyens
d'exister nous avions un club sportif
qui était le club phare de la côte
caraïbe auquel ce club aujourd'hui n'a
aucun moyen pour fonctionner d'ailleurs
il est rétrogradé à r2 et je peux vous
dire que nous avons je prends l'exemple
à l'époque casse pilotes on sait tous
que ce club de football réunis c'est pas
mal de personnes et le stade aujourd'hui
est tellement vétuste qui l'a même pas
y'a même pas de quoi éclairer les
joueurs pour jouer et s'entraîner donc
nous sommes dans une situation où le
cadre de vie des piles autun s'est
dégradée complètement à travers les
remontées d'administrer aux oies sans un
certain malaise les quartiers n'ont
aucun entretien et quand vous regardez
sur le front de mer c'est vrai il ya eu
quand même un travail qui a été fait
mais à l'intérieur des familles dans les
voies les routes et j'en passe je ne
parle même pas de l'élagage parce que on
est on est on est en train d'arriver à
des endroits où le les câbles
électriques et les les gens ne se
retrouvent plus vous avez des amas
d'ordures qui ceux qui se retrouvent et
se répète dans pas mal de quartier et ça
c'est déplorable pour une petite ville
avec à l'époque où nous avions connu
quand même à l'époque de monsieur alfred
régis un peu beaucoup mieux organisés et
beaucoup plus de moyens qu'avaient les
employés de la commune à l'époque justin
pour ceux qui ne savent pas qui est un
monsieur
régis était à l'aune des responsables du
service technique et qui travaillait
avec ses agents et c'était un monsieur
que je cite comme exemple c'est un
ancien footballeur aussi que le cs case
pilote a connu et ce monsieur
travaillait comme la comme le coût de
tout le monde il passait il vérifiait il
y avait il y avait cette symbiose entre
la population entre les employés ils
avaient des moyens pour travailler
aujourd'hui les agents du service
technique n'ont pas de moyens pour
travailler
ils n'ont pas cette motivation là et je
peux vous dire que lorsque vous les
écoutez monsieur mon plaisir mais ne
s'est peut-être pas mais vous avez les
employés de la commune qui achètent leur
propre matériel de protection
individuelle vous comprenez donc ce
n'est pas normal qu'une collectivité
bref conte plaisir vous répondez quoi
les agents du service technique n'ont
pas de moyens pour travailler ils sont
bien d'acheter leur propre matériel
écoutez moi je veux d'abord vous dire
que l'attractivité de la ville est là
parce que nous n'avons jamais eu autant
de gens qui veulent acheter quelque
chose pour habiter à 15 kg tous loués à
15 kg ciel n'était pas attractive ça
n'existerait pas ensuite les personnes
âgées ont un endroit où elles sont
depuis des années nous avons acheté un
immeuble
elles sont installées avant que nous
arrivions on les provenaient de coin
coin aujourd'hui depuis des années
maintenant elles ont leurs propres
installations elles sont heureuses elles
sont pas loin de l'église en plus haut y
aller nous avons des personnes qui vont
faire du sport des personnes âgées qui
vont faire du sport dans la mer parce
que c'est organisé grâce à ce que nous
avons pu faire le club sportif de
case-pilote journée était le président
quand j'étais président du club sportif
je suis arrivée le club avait un déficit
de 80 mille francs ils doivent est 80
mille francs à l'époque le commissaire
aux comptes s'étaient monsieur versier
monsieur certains étaient sortis de la
présidence monsieur daniel deux
instituteurs monsieur baril et et moi
même nous étions à au comité nous avions
d'ailleurs comme entraîneur monsieur
douce et bien le club sur le thon j'ai
été là est passé de deuxième en première
division
pendant toute la période où j'ai été
président du club tous les pilotins et
pilotine qui voulait aller au match
partout dans la martinique allait
gratuitement parce que j'avais mis en
place un bus qui transportait tout le
monde
avant le départ le club n'avait pas une
de 1 centime de dettes et était
propriétaire d'un bus donc je pense que
je sais ce que c'est que le club sportif
de case-pilote et je crois que l'on me
le rend sa mécanique s'amassent excusez
moi vous m'avez vous me laissez parler
parce que vous avez laissé mon collègue
je souhaite exprimer
oui c'est bon tu sais mon temps de
parole mais si mais si je vous explique
le club sportif de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui mais je veux réalisons de la
déchéance mais il n'y a pas de
définition cpj n'y a pas de déchéance
nous avons ré ouvrir une crèche à 15 kg
on est pas chez ces montants de parole
c'est moi qui vous répond nous avons
vers une crèche nous avons réouvert une
crèche à quinze pilotes coop de ça va
arriver en 2008 elle était fermée depuis
deux ans cette crèche est ouverte elle
fonctionne elle et nous n'avons pas
assez de place par la demande
quand nous avons repris la crèche nous
avons mis en place un système parce que
nous avons cherché à savoir comment il
fallait faire il nous a été conseillé
par des juristes une délégation de
service public ce qu'on a fait pendant
les quatre premières années la commune à
payer une somme pour que le délégataire
fonctionne et après au renouvellement
c'est la commune qui est payé par le
guide est délégataire nos en question de
l'argent grâce à la crèche
non nous avons on va avoir comme m 13
ans comme un art mais je vais vous
parler le château g20 comme je suis venu
pour ça
bien sûr vous même et on a ce que mais
non mais je peux vous dire ce que j'ai
fait il faut que l'on parle par exemple
du bilan financier delà de la situation
financière la situation l'anarchie
relais et je attendez on va parler avec
moi j'aimerais rct à moi que vous parle
pas on va poser d'abord merci à monsieur
car unique
monsieur calvi dit que vous êtes cons
ces municipales quelle est la situation
financière de la commune selon vous
écoutez je crois que depuis 12 ans je
suis le seul à dire que la commune est
très mal gérée en 2013 lors des
élections juste avant j'ai expliqué avec
conviction que la ville à pouvoir
déficit très important et que les conti
devaient avoir des impôts à payer
enfin aujourd'hui la chambre régionale
des comptes dit que la ville est arrivé
en équilibre en 2000
19 19 en décembre 2009 dernier dernier
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui date de novembre 2010 ne
faut pas se tromper il ya eu la vie de
la chance qu'ils donnaient l'exercice
2010 8 avec un déficit de 4 millions
cinq cent mille euros que les ans c'est
clair c'est net et donner un avis sur le
budget 2010 9 qui disait quoi qui disait
que ce sera les préconisations de la
ville il peut y avoir un retour à
l'équilibré mais s'il vous plaît
lorsqu'on ne connaît pas ou on est
incompétent on peut dire tout et
n'importe quoi simplement il fallait
qu'au 31 décembre de cette année que y
ait des voix cette nouvelle dit que
c'était prévu de vente du terrain et que
là le conseil municipal puisse faire ce
qu'on appelle des décisions
modificatives dîner autour du 1 décembre
il n'y a pas eu de d'édition brésil
samedi qu'il n'y a aucune vente de
terrains de fait seul vrai dire que le
déficit de 2018 sera beaucoup plus
important en 2019
alors lorsque j'ai entendu que monsieur
le métro tandis qu'on est à féliciter
pour sa gestion
je dirais simplement soyons raisonnables
à 2014 vous avez un déficit de 2
millions site
on vous donne un plan de redressement
vous augmentez les impôts de 34%
ce qui donne à la ville une recette de
1,2 million de aux chacals et à
l'exercice de dernière et si vous avez
un déficit de 4 millions 5
comment peut-on m'expliquer qu'avec des
nouvelles lois 7 1 milliards de et que
la ville est dans cet état là et que
aujourd'hui on veut me faire croire que
la ville a été bien gérée soyons
raisonnables
monsieur monsieur ton oui alors vous
savez j'ai été quand même celui qui
écrit à la chambre régionale des comptes
parce que vous savez que monsieur bon
plaisir s'est targué d'être sorti du
rouge alors que c'est totalement faux et
vous voyez je vais vous laisser ce
courrier vous allez l'analyser et vous
verrez très bien après ma demande maroc
est un formule auprès du du président de
la chambre régionale des comptes
il ya eu une réponse est la réponse je
vais pas vous le dire parce que ça va me
prendre pas mal de temps mais là vous
comprendrez tout de suite on est loin
d'être sorti en substance ce qu'a dit la
chambre jaune à douala
on est loin d'être sorti du déficit que
mais comme dit la chanson révélation
d'un pelé blanc je devrais vous résumer
rapidement
alors écoutez bien les mesures
suffisantes les mesures suffisant au
stade de budget prévisionnel ne signifie
donc pas que la situation de la
collectivité soit redevenu complètement
satisfaisante où prospèrent la situation
réelle ne peut être apprécié de manière
fiable que l'examen du compte
administratif qui suit donc la
championne dès qu'on prévoit à cet effet
que le préfet transmettent à la chambre
des comptes administratifs de l'exercice
dont elle a eu examen a su examiner le
budget prévisionnel pour qu'elle
constate la situation financière exacte
de la collectivité
donc ça signifie qu' on ne pourra savoir
réellement qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les finances de la ville à la suite
c'est bizarre enfin je proscrive de 2019
il se dit que la conçoit réellement
l'état des finances de la ville
aujourd'hui monsieur mon plaisir il vous
dit qu'il a vendu il a si la fille
rentrer de l'argent on ne peut pas
prendre de l'argent sur l'avant de
terrain qui fait partie du budget
d'investissement pour ajouter dans un
budget de fonctionnement qui interdit et
deuxièmement lorsque vous dites c'est
comme si vous avez un compte personnel
et du temps de banquier je suis en
déficit par rapport
j'ai les terrains des biens que je vais
vendre mais jusqu'à ce que vous n'est
pas vendu vous n'avez pas vendu les
terrains
vous n'avez pas pouvoir combler le
déficit dont un déficit
vous comprenez ce n'est que lorsque les
vents seront réelles réellement fait
qu'on saura si réellement les ventes ont
été faites à 4000 hommes mais pour
l'instant en rien de la n'a été signé et
décidé chez le notaire
alors monsieur mon plaisir vous êtes la
maire de la ville bon gestionnaire
mauvais gestionnaires c'est beaucoup ce
qu'on entend dans les rues de la ville
il ya une bataille entre pilotin / s
oui ou non la ville est dans une
situation financière stable critique ou
catastrophique
d'après frigories quand on est en
déficit on est obligé de faire son
budget de l'adresser à monsieur le
préfet qui l'envoie à la crc ce qu'on a
c'est assez laid vous le regarde fait
des suggestions discute avec vous
au terme des suggestions vous présenter
un budget à monsieur le préfet monsieur
le préfet l'acceptent ou le refusent
et quand il prend sa décision il vous
dit ben voilà soit vous faites ce budget
là vous le faites pas où toi d'abord
tous les budgets que nous avons
présentés dans ce cadre de la devant la
crc a toujours été acceptée par monsieur
le préfet comme étant des budgets qui
lui paraissait correct ensuite il y a
des choses différentes il ya
l'investissement le fonctionnement les 4
millions week end on parle mes amis ce
sont des désinvestissements cdc du
budget d'investissement
effectivement nous sommes en train de
vendre pour 10 millions d'euros
les terrains que dont faisait cadeau la
commune à quelqu'un gratuitement puisque
on offrait un terrain de 700000 euros
effet ip est 700000 euros et en
faisaient 700000 euros de route pour lui
aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est réglé
demain la séance et va même se prononcer
j'ai ici le papier de la séance et qui
dit que le rapporteur dit que ce n'est
pas valable ils ont fait un recours mais
ça ne sonnait pas valable donc nous
sommes effectivement signature de
promesse de vente et ses signatures vont
amener les somme de 9 millions 200 mille
euros
parce que nous offrons un terrain aux
pompiers ce terrain sur ce prix là vous
800000 euros monsieur nous aurons
dépensé 4 million deux cent mille euros
ou faire les routes et nous vendons 9
million deux cent mille euros plus huit
cent mille euros qu'on a faux bon pied
d'autres communes va gagner cinq
millions huit cent mille euros là demain
ça c'est une première chose nous avons
une deuxième terrain que nous vendons on
l'a acheté deux millions huit cent mille
euros monsieur carreaux nick ne voulait
pas que je l'achète
on vend sur 55 hectares on vend 11
hectares pour 8 millions et online pour
une une option de 7 hectares
supplémentaires pour arriver à 14
millions vous m'avez josé
sa région il n'y a pas un litige sur le
terrain quand vous avez vendu
justement non avertis vers 96 cents
s'était vu donc c'est fini mal à y jouer
mais mon collègue là vous donne des
papiers je vous les donne aussi à vous
pouvez constater qu'il n'ya pas de
litige le français a été réglée par la
cour d'appel et ensuite il y à une un
impôt voix mais le pouvoir n'a pas de
valeur et en plus le rapporteur a déjà
fait le rapport disant qu' il faut pas à
suivre le pouvoir donc j'en reviens
maintenant au budget lui-même le budget
lui-même le dernier budget
la crc nous a fait savoir qu'elle était
satisfaite parce que de nous avions
réduit
il nous avait dit fin déterminée avec
50000 euros d'excédent
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à ce
moment-là nous démarrions l'année avec
un budget déficitaire de l'ordre de 800
mille euros eh bien nous avons non
seulement réussi mais on a réussi à voir
en excédent de ce budget de 750 mille
euros on a gardé 50000 euros sur le
budget de fonctionnement et comme la loi
le permet on a envoyé sept cent mille
euros sur le budget de fonctionnement
excusez moi je termine je les remets aux
coudes à marcel et ses moteurs mais je
peux être beaucoup d'avancées lovech
mais juste pour finir pour vous dire que
aujourd'hui ce budget le préfet n'avait
pas le regarder la crc nous avons pas
besoin de le regarder effectivement
monsieur eugène a fait une remarque à la
crc la série s'était trompé de ligne
dans la la rédaction du budget c'est de
ce sont des lignes
voilà en tout cas merci car unique ce
que j'essaie de dire beaucoup de choses
en peu de temps
mais vous avez raison d'être le bruit
parce que j'ai autant mais en face de
moi j'ai deux personnes qui ont le même
temps que moi donc
mais oui mais c'est le quitter mais pas
les critères mais si on comptait 2 1
mais si nous valent également à
l'honneur ont perdu chacun monsieur sait
pas écouter ce caroni que je suis
président ne partagent pas cette analyse
de la situation financière de la ville
avait tout à fait
jean lemaire sont encore dit où tout et
le contraire le rapport la c1 c'est
clair il ya 1,7 million d'euros le
déficit en fonctionnement 2,8 millions
en investissement alors que là il vous
dit que c'est uniquement d'un
investissement
donc je ne vais pas faire le jure de ne
pas savoir exactement ce qu'il dit enfin
les choses sont claires concernant cette
affaire le tir et quand le maire sortant
dit qu'il n'y a pas de litige il ya un
recours en cassation qui dipose est
temps que nous n'avions pas joué à
laisser messi car nous n'avions pas non
c'est juste pour expliquer aux auditeurs
internet qui nous voient que je remets
quelques instants c'est inquiète mais
sur une fusion qui va valoriser votre
parole et je suis quasi qu'ils soient
chaque fruit mais monsieur mon plaisir
s'il vous plaît venir de radio france je
vous remercie j'ai prise il ya un risque
qu'ils courent
d'ailleurs nous avons compris c'est que
depuis des années la politique de la
majorité
c'est le profit le profit qui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'a pas profité à la ville
ça peut être profiter à d'autres mais ça
n'en a pas profité à la ville puisque il
n'y a pas eu d'emplois il n'y a pas eu
tout ce qui était proposé
tout ce qui avait été suggéré rien
n'était fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que nous sommes une agence immobilière
on achète on vend c'est du profit alors
que c'est pas la vocation du nil
c'est pas la politique d'une ville donc
il ya nous n'avons pas la même
conception des choses est que
aujourd'hui jeudi que le risque est là
le risque est là pour la ville
me lemaire dit que tout est réglé ce
n'est pas vrai la carapace au verdict
l'épée de damoclès est encore sur la
tête des lots de monique vous avez dit
quelque chose de vraiment je rappelle
juste que vous êtes un peu en retard si
je vis de certaines paroles avant votre
cette intervention monsieur mon résultat
une minute vous à quatre minutes et
monsieur le jeune à 5 minutes 15 2 une
précision vous venez dire quelque chose
d'important
la ville n'est pas une agence
immobilière nous sommes opposés moi-même
et monsieur mon plaisir sur la
conception la vision de la gestion de la
commune
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
deux mots en quoi vos visions sont si
différentes
mais ma vision est différente parce que
nous avons le tirer du cabinet pwc elle
possède du foncier nous n'avons pas
d'effacer ce qu ont suffisamment pour
recevoir des populations lorsqu'on voit
ce terrain pour faire la construction on
a même une population alors que nous
avons venir les offrir il n'y a pas de
salle des fêtes et après il ya pas de
sport il ya rien de depuis paris donc on
n'a pas la même vision des choses
moi moi je plaide pour une politique
pour assurer le bien-être de la
population que lui donner les moyens de
ses bagnon dans sa commune à ce propos
juste ce qui est important monsieur
vraiment plaisir a dit mais monsieur 40k
l'instant la ville de caen ce pilote a
connu une certaine attractivité dix ans
ces trente dernières années la ville
s'est considérablement développée il ya
trente ans la ville avait même pas de
1000 habitants
aujourd'hui à quatre mille cinq cents
environ la population s'est stabilisée
bon comme dans beaucoup de communes
martinique
mais là on a l'impression que quand une
autre marque dont il manque un petit
quelque chose pour passer au palier
supérieur comme si cette attractivité
avait cessé ses partisans mais c'est
votre sentiment absolument pas si vous
l'indiquions comme c'est votre sentiment
la ville de l'aquila et erre grande
attractivité
puis le manque et bertrand ainsi
monsieur le jeune à paroles match
monsieur g de la parole et vous en
remercie
y'a rien de chose de très important nous
sommes sur une ville de 4000 553
habitants
quand vous passez à castres vous n'avez
qu'à demander les gens se disent mais
effectivement la ville ans on sent que l
envie de respirer mais elle n'y arrive
pas il n'ya pas l'attractivité
je n'ai qu'à regarder le maire dit que
tout va bien pour le stade c'est pas
vrai le stade n'a pas l'éclairage ont
parlé quand vous parlez d'attractivité
vous parlez de quoi exactement qu'est ce
qu'il manque
parce que mais vous avez des
associations qui n'ont aucun moyen de
s'exprimer lorsque vous avez à peu près
une vingtaine d'associations dans l'est
dans la vingtaine vous avez que deux qui
touchent des subventions qu'on pourrait
très bien que les autres ne peuvent pas
le milieu associatif c'est un milieu
très important c'est une soupape pour
une société et elle ne peut pas
s'exprimer pour passer dans la cité
manie bas il n'y a pas de lumière vous
passez dans les croisés ya pas de
lumière vous avez dans certains cas
entier un manque de df sculptures et
c'est bien ça tombe bien parce que
lorsque vous voyez que monsieur
montplaisir qui a tendance à vendre tout
pour payer les dettes et déficits de la
ville il faut penser au futur
moi je suis un jeune homme politique et
je veux apporter une vision contraire à
sa vision pourquoi parce que vous
arrivez dans la boue la case pilote n'y
a pas de place il ya il faut développer
cette ville on a besoin d'attractivité
il faut permettre à cette ville
mais le plus dominé sort quand même non
oui je ne dis pas le contraire mais on
est limité aujourd'hui la ville a besoin
de s'agrandir
il faut recevoir plus de personnes
aujourd'hui soit le redire le bourg
comme les accords très simple paraît
qu'il est arrivé il ya des gens qui
arrivent à case-pilote mais la station
d'épuration d'eau elle est saturée
vous vous retrouvez avec des excréments
lorsqu'il pleut des instruments sur le
sur la voie publique sur la route
nationale
voyez il ya monsieur beauport jean luc
qui se plaît de partout en face de son
son commerce il est très mécontent parce
que vous avez des dd de reflux deroff lé
dakor pied ça sur l exemple où on peut
vous témoigner que la ville ne s'est pas
adaptée à l'arrivée des autres
populations
il faut développer cette ville par
l'attractivité il faut
qui est de l'emploi il faut qu on puisse
recevoir des gens dans un autre cadre de
vie alors donné la confiance à
case-pilote à case-pilote il y avait la
fête patronale qui a disparu et avec
nous avec mon équipe on va remettre à
l'actualité la fête communale de
gaspillage monsieur le maire sortant
monsieur reif montplaisir des
instruments sur sur la route des
quartiers pas éclairé alors que vous
êtes président du semaine ça fait
beaucoup quand même à fait normalement
surtout que l'est la commune d'aniche
station d'épuration pour traiter 7500
usagers et qu'elle en a quatre mille
cinq cents et que les 4500 ne sont pas
tous branchés sur la station c'est pour
vous dire qu'en réalité sur monsieur ne
connais pas ce qui se passe à 15 pilotes
s'ils savaient ils ne dirais pas qu'il
ya une station d'épuration qui est un
sous l'immense y ont elles mêmes sur
dimensionner les exos les bancaires
remontent les excréments qui remonte
monsieur ce ne sont pas du ressort du
maire
il s'agit de la smr qui elle même dépend
de quatre noms qui a été appelé
plusieurs fois par la mairie c'est un
problème à l'intérieur de la station
d'épuration comme moi je ne peux pas
traitées il y à un tuyau de refoulement
qui est trop haut et est de ce fait leur
part par là où elvis les eskers m'arrive
par la sorte par où il arrive c'est un
problème technique qui ne dépend pas de
la mairie
alors permettez moi de vous dire que ce
n'est pas du tout vrai et ensuite
en ce qui concerne les 34 %
d'augmentation d'impôts je suis très
surpris que vous rendez compte 34 % vous
rendez compte deux succès sachez que la
commune à ce qu'on appelle une part
communale des impôts ce sont des choses
qui sont le gouvernement la collectivité
et la collectivité d'agglo la ctm et
puis là google
la queen par une petite part vous avez
comme et si on regarde les yeux si vous
regardez les les feuilles d'impôt de
2017 2018 et celle de 2,2 qui viennent
vous verrez 2010 qu il y a eu
effectivement un moment donné l'année
dernière une petite augmentation parce
que ça faisait cinq ans que le la cour
des comptes voulait qu'on augmente on a
été obligé de céder mais par contre
cette année compte tenu du résultat du
fait que nous ne sommes plus au déficit
tout le monde pourra constater sur sa
feuille d'impôts quand il la recevra en
regardant les colonies
comparant aussi bien l'impôt la taxe
foncière et immobilière ils verront
qu'effectivement il y a eu une démission
une diminution
monsieur car on est juste un point
jeunes filles je suis et moi parce que
j'ai tellement de choses à dire il avait
beaucoup d'avancé 10 minutes 30 secondes
six minutes 15 pour monsieur eugène et
sa tunique est ce bon monsieur eugène et
six minutes 15 secondes scaroni que
j'interpelle sur l'attractivité que
faudrait il qu'il fait d'après vous je
pense que la créativité mais je voudrais
quand même aux mondiaux ce que monsieur
vous plaisir a dit que les époux
concernés les impôts à 2014 en 2013 ce
mot plaisir jouer à la population qui
augmente à sion impôts dormez bien mes
enfants ne voient pas le 11 septembre
2014 ils prennent des libérations pour
augmenter les jeunes ce n'est pas vrai
je m'exprime info il ya les conseils
municipaux ce n'est pas vrai les impôts
n'ont pas été augmentés à case-pilote
depuis que je suis là sauf quand il ya
la fameuse année bon c'est tout monsieur
caron et continuer on nous connaît je
vois les images thermiques
monsieur le président si vous pouvez
vous et moi j'ai été revu ainsi que je
suis navré 9 7 novembre de la même année
il prend une autre délibération donc
déjà 10 34 % d'impôts je sais de quoi je
parle
les chiffres sont têtus et vous rendez
compte de chaque cycle 34%
mais bien sûr mais vous rendez compte de
ce que j'ai fait mais je me suis obligé
pas d argent puisque ce cas je m'excuse
mais excusez moi monsieur karim à l'oise
moi je pense le coach et qui était
conseiller municipal
donc du temps des lilas il 2014 rit oui
excusez moi oui monsieur très à l'aise
il était il est cet homme 2014 et à 5
novembre 2014 lorsque vous dites que
c'est pas vous n'avez pas les impôts je
suis désolé revenez à labrador ou quoi
passe vous la vérité elle est toujours
là moi je ne suis pas là pour accoter
n'est pas en quoi je crois que je
maîtrise suffisamment les sujets de la
ville pour le pas dire n'importe quoi
donc si vous d'être cassé l'année
dernière quand vous avez augmenté non
effectivement il ya eu d'augmentation en
2016 100 % en 2010 80% mais tout le
reste vous avez voté par délibération
alors pour se glisser partout on parle
beaucoup
les impôts mais ce que là aujourd'hui la
commune dispose d'autres ressources pour
pauvres je sais pas pour se développer
kwal pense que monsieur monsieur de
saint eugène alors y'a il ya un manque
d'attractivité c'est sur ce qui est
regrettable c'est qu'on n'a pas créé
d'emplois casse pilote une ville on
arrive au 21e siècle on a besoin de
création d'emplois et nous avec l'équipe
que je aux 3 une équipe dynamique
nous allons faire en sorte que crée
cette attractivité pour donner de la
confiance aux jeunes tout à fait alors
ça commence bien entendu par assainir
les finances de la ville et autrement si
vous entrez dans les conflits juridiques
comme ça a été fait par monsieur mon
plaisir pour prôner très bien que vous
aller chasser les gens parce que alors
nous parlons nous sommes en 2020 jusqu'à
mettre dans depuis 2008 mais bien vu il
y avait une promesse de centres
commerciaux il y avait des entreprises
j'avais plein de choses qui avait été
prévu et rien de tout cela n'a vu le
jour
pourquoi parce que je prends l'exemple
du vétiver
à l'époque tous les pilotins savent que
le vétiver était le fleuron de la carte
de la côte caraïbe où les gens venaient
s'épanouir dans pour ceux qui me
connaissent grâce c'est un centre de
loisirs qui se situe maintenant motivés
ont sué avant d'arriver chez cmc
séquence edf
oui aujourd'hui ça me fait mal au coeur
de voir que ce quartier qui était si
beau parent avant que les piloter en
connu à l'époque je je je pense aux
crabes d'or à l'époque le grand saut
caen où il y avait si vous voulez cette
cérémonie gramley tout le monde de toute
la côte caraïbe et et j'en passe il nous
manque justement le retour des idées
nouvelles et pour cela je vais créer le
musée de l'attractivité d'un musée de la
tactique oui c'est un musée participatif
qui va faire en sorte que toutes les
familles de casse pilotes pourront
exposer des idées nouvelles et objets
d'antan et c'est ce musée va permettre à
des gens comme monsieur denis fortin qui
allie jeux d'antan parce que les
écoliers de toutes deux
les écoles de martinique j'ai la case
pilote ça c'est un moyen de valoriser
les familles qui c'est ce qui manque à
ce pilote on le donne pas assez de
valorisation à des projets qui sont de
chez nous vous avez connu le cheval voix
de monsieur boston souvent le cas c'est
une terre du chouval bwa le manège le
fameux manèges d'antan
il faut redonner justement cette vision
par le biais de ce musée parce que les
jeunes devront connaître les jeux
d'antan par la famille de monsieur ford
mais également n'importe quelle famille
pour exposer un objet ou où j'en passe
mais c'est dans ce bus et cars au nez
comme c'est lui que c'est vous qui avez
le temps de parole puisque vous êtes le
moins disert dix ans l'attractivité pour
employer un terme semble que faudrait-il
pour que d'autres personnes ou des
entreprises ou d'autres services
viennent s'installer dans la ville ou en
tout cas qu'elle retrouve le lustre
d'antan que vous semblez tous dit vous
vous attendiez que c'était un peu mieux
avant et boccace du lot est un peu en
train de stagner est-ce que c'est aussi
il faut être aussi sévère
je le dis oui c'est vrai je connais que
vous la fête patronale est un moment et
pourtant traditionnels dans la commune
qui permettait à chaque pilote est de se
retrouver autour des valeurs communes de
partager des moments forts
d'où les piloter de l'hexagone connaît
rendez vous gouvernez ans le 15 août en
vacances pour se retrouver avec les
pilotins ils étaient reçus par la
mensualité
il y avait une communion entre les plus
différentes populations et les seuils de
l'hexagone tout cela a disparu c'est à
dire aujourd'hui nous avons une fête de
quartier
même les jeunes de l'excellent york qui
avait l'habitude de venir pour le 15
août se dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils qu'est
ce qui se passe dans la commune pour
voiliers c'est tout c'est vous avez on a
des notes les associations n'ont même
pas une journée de carnaval pendant les
quatre jours
même pas puisque c est ce que c'est le
maire la municipalité qui doit organiser
ou est ce que la municipalité accompagne
des initiatives brill social alain dinin
visibilité accompagné association a
partout le moment qu'elle a commencé à
faire ce travail minitieusement de
démanteler tous
mais effectivement toutes les parties
les associations ne peuvent plus ils ont
pu le plus de moyens pendant les
vacances il y avait toujours de
l'animation pour les jeunes sur la
commune
rien de tout cela c'est le cas
aujourd'hui je dis clairement que le la
le conseil municipal l'équipe municipale
au top ne s'occupe pas de la ville ne
s'occupe pas de la population vous
passez dans le centre-bourg je prends un
exemple simple quand il pleut si vous
passez vous verrez pas attention lorsque
ne voit que parce voudrait tsahal et
vous êtes mouillés
les rues sont dans un état lamentable
même au niveau du sport pour que les
jeunes puissent s'épanouir pour
l'éclairage du sport du stade c'est une
difficulté alors qu'on a voté des plans
de financement dans la commune avec 5500
euros à m oui pour moi je c'est clair
cette équipe municipale à elle a fait
son temps elle a raté sa mission
donc elle devrait partir alors 1.1 point
sur le thème paroles vous êtes à 10
minutes chacun et il nous reste en tout
six minutes disant démission avant les
conclusions conclusion inaugurait une
minute pour l'avenir de la ville en deux
mots en deux phrases deux idées
massivement plaisir comment voyez vous
l'avenir de la ville si vous êtes
heureux élus merkel sera le dossier
prioritaire le chantier prioritaire à
mettre en avant pour assurer l'avenir
peut-être au-delà de ce bonheur parce
qu'on sait bien que le maire n'a pas
forcément la possibilité de tout
construit en six ans quand je suis
arrivé aux affaires j'avais présenté un
projet en parlant avec un maire de
métropole qui m'a dit mais monsieur vous
faudra trois mandats je lis jamais de la
vie sans le mandat je me suis rendu
compte qu'il avait raison
nous sommes sur le point de terminer
effectivement nous avons pas pu lancer
les projets qu'on voulait pendant 11 ans
parce que nous étions procès pendant
onze ans pour récupérer notre terrain on
l'a récupéré ça chez kafka case-pilote
qu'il y aura un parking silo de 209
place là où il y avait l'ancien
l'ancienne casse vous me demandez en
trois minutes de vous résumer douze ans
de mandat et de ce que je vais faire de
jouer vous répondre que je ne peux pas
que les gens constatent rond pendant la
campagne
ce que je présenterai mais je peux vous
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont en route
bonnes choses qui ont été étudiées et
beaucoup de choses qu'ils s'affaireront
alors quelles sont les grandes lignes de
votre programme question est grand il
faut aller vite parce que le programme
il est vraiment important chez nous mais
il faut prendre en compte que la commune
un déficit très important donc on va
d'abord par tient sur une réorganisation
des services
on va créer la première police plots et
communale de la martinique c'est à dire
c'est à dire c'est une police qui va
pouvoir travailler en intercommunalité
avec les moyens que possèdent des autres
villes on va travailler il faut tout de
suite mettre à l'abri les écoliers vous
avez vu ce qui s'est passé à trinidad à
porto rico
jeudi dernier les écoles de case-pilote
ne sont plus protégés avec le plan barre
j'ai passé à présent les côtes de ces
îles en une semaine un sig a le même
séisme à la martinique et deux écoles
les deux écoles se retrouvent les fonds
devaient complètement effondré sur les
écoliers il faudra bénéficier du plan
barnier pour réhabiliter ces écoles il
faut déplacer la crèche qui se trouve
dans un lieu très dangereux est la
crèche pour être rétabli et reconstruit
en payant zéro euro par la caf
aujourd'hui la caf ont reconstruit les
crèches il faut mettre en place
également le tourisme
il faut mettre en place la partie sport
et culture il faudra mettre en place
également la fiscalité
parce qu'aujourd'hui en martinique le
tout ce qui est les taxes foncières sont
vus al'inverse de la martinique et de la
métropole aujourd'hui en métropole
lorsque vous avez des bâtis non
construite la taxe foncière ou coûte en
martinique moins chère alors que
lorsqu'elle elle est construite et coûte
plus cher nous on va s'attaquer sur sur
ce point là on va également voir tout ce
qui est casernement de pompiers il
faudra voir si le plan éducation les
enfants les écoliers il faut mettre à
case-pilote une médiathèque
on n'a pas de collège on n'a pas de
lycée on se retrouve avec l'unique pas
des écoles primaires les tous les
écoliers de case-pilote pas par la suite
pour les lycées d'à côté on à
l'université on a les collèges il faut
créer cette médiathèque qui va permettre
à ces élèves de se retrouver ensemble
parce que l'éducation c'est une priorité
pour notre groupe ensemble pour le
changement ghazal et vous risquez d'être
mise
minute de conclusion musical unique oui
c'est à dire concernant quatre ya
tellement de choses à faire mais je veux
quand même deux choses
ces deux gros investissements que la
ville a fait est que depuis 12 ans il ya
rien de fait je prends des lacs i
l'acquisition de l'auberge du barrez
plus de 900000 euros jusqu'à aujourd'hui
elle est exploitée
donc nous pensons réhabiliter ce
bâtiment pour faire un centre culturel
pour que les pilotins puisse avoir les
moyens de s'exprimer
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est je parle du terrain du qu'un
maintien du cap doit être aménagé en
quatre zones différentes
une zone dédiée aux petites et moyennes
entreprises des zones d'aidé dédié à
l'environnement et touristique
aménagement de paris sportifs câble sat
et pas ou peu de tout de manière qui est
un lieu pour que les gens s'expriment
s'épanouissent il ya de la place il ya
46 7 3 et donc il ya de quoi faire là le
deuxième ce programme immobilier qui
pourrait effectivement fait de
l'accession à la propriété pour des
maisons de pour les seniors surtout un
centre médical de manière qui est deux
appartements disponibles et signant une
convention avec des médecins en cinq ans
6e 7e année pour qu'ils puissent se
loger là est cueilli une permanence sur
la commune pendant toute la période
le dernier point c'est permis de
casseroles d'avoir un outil performant
sadique un palais omnisports modules à
qui pourra recevoir trois mille
personnes qui pourraient utiliser
utilisé pour la martinique
leur local qui pourrait recevoir des
activités sportives internationales
nationales de manioc la casse note
on retrouve tout sportif
merci beaucoup alors nous arrivons au
terme de cette émission nous passons
donc à la minute
de conclusions nous allons commencer par
vous reste une minute là je vais vous
dire la bonne c'est que à ce que j' ai
goûté 15 pilotes c'est vraiment la
situation est extrême extrêmement grave
il s'agit de faire peur à tout le monde
moi je vais vous répondre que quinze
pilotes se développe
je vais vous dire que il y a des projets
qui ont été énumérés et pour lesquels il
faudrait que ces gens là se renseignent
dans ce que c'est déjà les choses pour
lesquelles on a même des permis en cours
qui ils niquent et tout ça ensuite je
vais vous dire quelque chose quand on
vient et qu'on se présente comme
candidat en frappent aux portes
on frappe pour dire aux gens je
souhaiterais pouvoir vous aider
satisfaire vos besoins
c'est à dire consommer au service et
pierre aliker avait dit à sa nièce et
senna dicaire tu vas en politique
sache que tu ne vas pas pour te servir
mais tu vas pour servir ses recettes
galoper que je suis maire de personnes
qui vient me voir quelle qu'elle soit
mais monsieur car onyx il a besoin de
quelque chose je le reçois les bras
ouverts pour pouvoir l'aider et lui
donner ce que je peux lui donner
merci bonne année à tout le monde et
puis s'il compte en moins voté bas - dès
le premier tour monsieur k roddick
je dirais simplement à la population à
case-pilote les mêmes les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets en 2013 on a
vendu du rêve
c'est exactement comme un vendeur de
voitures qui vend du rêve nous et
clients et après c'est le chaos total
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer
salut qu'à la com et est dans une
situation auquel que si on ne prend pas
je trouve qu'on ne peut assurer le
redressement de la ville on ne pouvait
pas avancer ce à dire qu'il faudrait
prendre les bonnes décisions pour de
sorte à faire une gestion qu est plutôt
d'un loup et des sanitaires hommes à 62
mille euros par année on aurait pu
construire des sanitaires par le service
actif de la ville on achète un bâtiment
250000 euros
on se lève le matin on la détruit dont
on plutôt de chati l'argent
on peut faire mieux avec l'argent des
piloter pour qu'ils puissent également
être sur les jeunes alors je dis à la
population
vous savez nous sommes à 20 minutes par
la mère du terminus de bateau qui se
trouve au pied de cet immeuble
vous avez un bateau comme le bateau de
croisière qui s'appelle le msc qui
arrive avec 5000 passagers
juste à côté de ce bateau vous avez un
ponton où se trouve une navette qui
dessert la capitale à case-pilote c'est
inadmissible d'avoir cinq mille
croisiéristes qui arrive sur le sol de
la capitale et qu'il n'y en ait pas un
qui monte sur cette navette qui ayakashi
l'autre on mettra en place des circuits
touristiques et c'est un exemple de ce
que l'on pourra faire
parmi la quinzaine de points que je peux
pas vous citer ce soir et j'aurai
l'occasion de me présenter à la
population avec mon groupe ensemble pour
le chemin 15 pilotes pour apporter une
vision claire de mer qui n'attendra pas
l'élection municipale pour se présenter
à eux qu'à ce pilote a besoin de cette
proximité de mer qui sera à l'écouté de
la population qui sera avec ses équipes
sur le terrain et qui protège la
population aujourd'hui mais un sens aux
risques majeurs
on n'a aucun abri pouvant abriter notre
population fait confiance à elle seule
de gênes tête de liste ensemble pour le
changement anc à ce pilote et vous
verrez que votre vie or à bien notre
cadre de vie de ce qu'il vit
actuellement qu'elle suit le maire fao
la bouche ou achat mais bravo à charge
et mes droits et mes j'avais pas même et
au fusil sur la tempe
si je parle mais foutez pas de sens si
vous voulez mais pas d'où part la bouche
pas shalit mais nous sommes je suis une
radio le déterminer
merci parce que ses films et ses films
et oui oui je vais rester
merci beaucoup
ici j'ai pas pu dire merci à martin bien
c'est dans ces termes il espère merci
merci jean marc ben si c'est sur cette
démo ezio dans cette électricité que me
suis lassé le chaînon glissez-vous dans
la radio du peuple terminer notre
émission convenablement
je vous remercie cette émission était
réalisée dans des conditions un peu
spécial vous le voyez par jean lain
bongo que je remercie pour son sang
froid avec la participation de muriel
tauziat et de berne contre bruges
ce débat sera en revanche sur notre site
internet très bientôt
la prochaine émission débat aura lieu ce
vendredi 7 janvier madame monsieur merci
a bientot aux élections municipales le
débat